Hello world.
It's Saroj and how would you suppose to
train all these deep learning algorithms
if you don't have an amazing GPU?
We're going to talk about why gps
are important for deep learning.
Then I'll show you how to train a big
style transfer model in the cloud.
Super easily.
A central processing unit or CPU
acts as the brain of a computer.
It's a small square like component
with a bunch of short rounded metallic
connectors on its underside like bender.
Hi my shiny metal ash.
It's fundamental operation.
It's called an instruction.
Every computer has both a CPU and memory,
so when you run a binary file like
an exe which contains instructions,
the oos copies the program into memory
then feeds it to the CPU one instruction
at a time. The basic computation
unit of a CPU is called a core.
It can run a given task.
It does things like maintain the program
state and the correct execution order.
It can use one or more cores to
perform a task. I'd a given time.
CPU is generally don't have more than 12
cores and our men for general computing
tasks.
There are some tasks that can only be
executed sequentially like doing the
Danny,
Susan.
Some tasks though can be run in parallel.
In fact,
they would benefit from parallelization
rendered. Graphics is a great example.
Each pixel can be processed independently
of the others and so to help do this,
the graphics processing
unit or Gpu was invented.
Modern GPS can have up to
a thousand cores or more.
They're made for parallel computation.
A single GPU is like lots of
little CPS all running at once.
CPS are optimized for latency.
They're good at fetching small
amounts of memory quickly.
While GPU is optimized for bandwidth,
they're good at fetching large
amounts of memory all at once.
Lighting and shading effects require
massive matrix operations to be calculated
all at once and the GPU
helps make this happen.
It just so happens that another use
case that involves an ungodly amount of
matrix operations that can be
parallelized is deep learning.
Every computer needs a GPU. Do
you have one too? Without it,
you wouldn't see an image on your display,
but the question for deep learning is
should you get a dedicated GPU or should
you use the cloud building your
own rig if you do it right,
can be the most cost efficient method.
The Best Gpu overall in terms of
computing power is the Titan XP.
If you have a moderate budget,
then the GTX 10 60 is your best bet and
if you're on a tight budget and the GTX
10 50 I should be your goto.
It's kind of like when the
Internet was first coming of age,
everyone had an opinion on whether or
not to host their website on their own
hardware or use the cloud. Eventually
though, the industry standard became the,
because maintaining hardware
wasn't unwanted hassle.
Call one 800 train that shit.com wait,
so which cloud providers should you use?
Let's talk about three AWS,
Google cloud and Floy hub.
Amazon's cloud offering is currently
the industry standard and many big names
rely on it.
There are three types of instances
or virtual servers that AWS offers.
The first is on demand.
This lets you rent an instance with a
specific capacity that you can start and
stop as you need to.
When you restart it,
it picks up right where you left off
and only running instances are built.
Then there are reserved
instances for these.
You commit to paying for a number
of them for a certain period of time
beforehand.
The payoff for your commitment is that
these are half the price of on demand
instances. Then there are spot
instances. These are the cheapest option.
They are the spare computing capacity
that Amazon has at any given moment.
You have to get on them.
If you're outbid,
your spot instance is
terminated automatically and
they can't be stopped and
restarted,
only terminated so you can't just resume
where you left off heady later time.
Aws is dope sauce extreme,
but there are a lot of steps to get
started with it in the learning curve is
quite steep. So how does it compare it
to Google cloud when it comes to pricing?
Google cloud wins a two CPU eight Gig Ram
incense will cost $69 a month with AWS
compared to only $52 a
month on Google cloud.
It offers a pay per minute model
instead of a pay per hour model,
which is useful if you have
short on the flight tests to run.
That means that 2.01 hours of compute
on Google cloud is equivalent to three
hours on AWS.
Well,
AWS offers a generous one year free trial
in which you can use seven 50 hours a
month of a small CPU instance who will
cloud offers you $300 worth of credit for
12 months and an unlimited time three
tier. It still beat by AWS though.
In terms of number of offerings.
If you need a cloud sequel solution,
you can use my sequel with Google cloud,
but AWS offers a bunch
of different options.
Google cloud is more flexible
when it comes to configuring
your instances though.
They let you customize how many CPS and
how much ram to use and it has something
called preemptive instances,
which is similar to Amazon's spot
instances except you don't need to bid.
It can run for up to 24 hours but could
be interrupted by Google if they need
the computing power.
So if choosing between the two,
while AWS offers more cloud options,
Google cloud is cheaper and easier to use,
but there's another even newer option.
Floyd hub.
If you are a beginner or just
want to try out cloud computing,
this is the best option.
You get a hundred free hours of GPU
usage and you don't need a credit card to
sign up.
They offer per second billing and under
the hood they are using AWS reserved
instances but are providing
simplicity as a service.
It's like Heroku for deep learning.
Let's test it out by deploying a style
transfer model to it for training
ourselves. The first step is to create
an account on Floyd hub. Easy enough.
Then we'll want to install the Floyd
command line tool using the python package
manager hip.
This tool will let us interact with the
Floyd hub cloud directly from terminal.
Once that's installed,
we can use this tool to
help us authenticate with
the server via Floyd login.
We can paste are off token in as well.
Then we can clone that style transfer
repository directly from get hub to our
local machine.
Once it's downloaded,
we can CD into the main directory and
initialize it as a Floyd hub project.
We'll call it style transfer.
Now we're ready to run the model.
We can run it by wrapping the python run
command for the main file inside of the
Floyd run command. This repository
has some flags that we can use,
so we'll go ahead and specify
the style we want to use.
The directory will save our checkpoint
to output is a special path meant to
store checkpoints on Floyd hub, we can
define what images we want to test on,
how much influence we want the content
went to have on this style transfer and
the number of iterations to train for.
Oh,
and of course the data
source we want to train on.
That's all it takes to run and
now it's training in the cloud.
What this has done is it's saint
our local code to the cloud,
spun up a GPU instance,
set up an environment with tensorflow
installed and executed our command in that
environment.
Once it's running we can easily check
the status of it in terminal using the
status command and the ID of our run
or we can view it in the web dashboard.
Under slash experiments. We can also
view the logs using the logs command,
which will show all our print statements
and we can monitor training right here
if we wanted to.
If we make a change to this code locally,
we can just rerun the
project with the run command.
Floyd hub will upload a new version of
the code and start another run of the
project so it's gotten version control
built in just like yet. In fact,
it versions the entire pipeline code
data parameters and environment for exact
reproducibility.
Floyd hub uses a content addressing
scheme for both runs and datasets.
If there is a particular Dataset we
want to train on again and again,
it's useful to just upload it directly.
If we have it in our current directory,
we can just create the remote directory
for our data and name it using Floyd
data in it and our nay.
Then we can upload it using data upload.
We can use this data id for
any model we'd run later on.
It takes about eight hours to train this
model and when it's done we can test it
out by running the evaluate script,
giving it some fresh images to style
transfer by pointing it to our images
directory.
When it's done,
we can observe the output by running
the upper command using the run id.
Much deepness. All
right, let's cut the Hay.
If you want the absolute cheapest option
and are willing to deal with the hassle.
Building a custom deep learning machine
is the way to go and link to how to do
that. In the description. Aws and Google
cloud are two great cloud platforms.
Aws offers more cloud products
and is the industry standard.
A Google cloud is cheaper
and easier to use.
And Floyd hub is the easiest way to train
your models in the cloud and the best
way for beginners to get started,
please hit that subscribe button
for more programming videos.
Check out this related video. And for
now, I've got to fly to Amsterdam,
so thanks for watching.